At AMD, we believe in supporting
transparent, independent coverage that
helps customers make informed decisions.
Ah, do you then? Well, then why the
houble hockey sticks didn't you want to
send us an 8 gig version of the 960 XT?
Oh, it was based on regional market
demand. Well, the last time I checked,
we have a global audience. So, um,
unless there's no demand for a review in
the region of
Earth, I don't really get that
explanation. No, the more likely reason
is that you were afraid that we would
roast your 5060 competitor as hard as we
roasted the 5060, so you put off sending
it until we wouldn't have time to test
it before the embargo. But, we can talk
more about your shenanigans later.
First, the 9060 XT 16 gig promises to be
the best value card with a 60 in the
name in about half a decade, matching
the 5060 Ti 8 gig in performance,
outdoing it with double the VRAMm and
beating it on price, which sounds great,
but it also might not be the right thing
to buy. And I'll tell you why after I
tell you something you do want to buy
from our sponsor, Rocket Money. Take
back control of your finances and start
saving with Rocket Money's subscription
cancelling, bill negotiation, and
budgeting features. Get started for free
using our link in the video description.
[Music]
1080p is both the most popular gaming
resolution today and the most popular
excuse for shipping kneecapped 8 gig
cards like the 8 gig RTX 5060 which we
purchased for this review since Nvidia
really doesn't seem to want reviewers
testing those. But with all that said,
the truth is if you are playing games at
1080, AMD and Nvidia are probably right.
It is enough for now, but remember guys,
this is the minimum spec for new AAA
titles, and these are cards that cost
$300
plus. Anywh who, across our suite of
games that exist today, the 960 XT
performs admirably, but not
spectacularly, keeping up with the 5060
Ti cards, which cost at least $30 more
and asserting a commanding lead over the
anemic 5060 nonTi. It outperforms its
last gen counterpart, the 7600 XT, by
more than 30% most of the time, which is
enough to highlight how truly awful that
card was, but not enough to make the
Intel ARC B580 look like a bad value.
Intel's really standing out with their
battle mage architecture. Of course, we
would have loved to give you guys 8 gig
numbers. So, this is merely conjecture,
but at 1080p raster, you can expect
pretty much identical performance
numbers because it's essentially the
same card, sands half of the memory. If
we find time to throw one on the bench,
we will have that linked at LT Labs down
below. Okay, so what about the value
proposition? Well, that depends. See,
the 9060 XT actually comes in three
variants. The 8 gig one that didn't
arrive on time, the base clocked 16 GB
model, and the OC variant from Sapphire
that was sent to us. This one has higher
power draw and boosted clocks compared
to 16 gig nonoC cards. But other than
that, all of the variants are built on
the exact same Nav'i 44 GPU based on
AMD's RDNA4 architecture. This new
architecture brings a bunch of
improvements that you can get a deep
dive into in our 9070 series review, but
here's the short version. Big
improvements in ray tracing and AI that
bring these cards up to speed almost
with Nvidia in non-traditional forms of
rendering and a host of other
improvements that allow them to
sometimes even beat Nvidia in
traditional raster. Despite its similar
sounding name though, these new GPUs are
substantially cut down compared to their
bigger brothers with about half as many
compute units as the 9070 XT. Basically,
they did this, which means we have half
the memory bus width, but benefit from
keeping the same IO and 16 PCIe Gen 5
lanes. That last point is key for gamers
who are holding on to older systems
where a by8 interface like on some of
Nvidia and Intel's cards can result in a
measurable performance loss. Oh, there
is one thing I lied about on the IO.
Interestingly, this card only has three
display outputs. Now, most of you
declared this to be a non-issue after
the announcement, but it is the first
time that I've seen a $300 card in years
that didn't have four outputs. I
digress, though. To compensate for the
cut down die, AMD bumped up the clock
speed so that you'll get a bit more than
literally half of the performance of the
9070 XT, which is also why the card
draws a bit over half the power in line
with the 5060Ti 8 gig that AMD positions
it against. And in combuster, our card
seems to be right in line with the 5060
Ti 8 gig. But interestingly, the story
is a bit different in F-124.
In this racing game, AMD's latest pulls
an average 174 watts with a maximum
spike of 225 watts. By comparison, the
5060Ti 8 gig averages around 121 watts.
Now, we don't know if this behavior will
show up in every game, but this is
enough for us to recommend going for a
slightly beefier power supply than the
450 W unit that AMD recommends.
Thankfully, this is still relatively low
power draw, meaning that these cards are
pretty easy to tame. And even loaded by
a power virus like Combuster, our card
stayed both cool and quiet. Let's talk
1440p gaming. AMD claimed 6% better
gaming performance than the 5060 Ti 8
gig at 1440, but looking at our raster
results, we just don't see it. They
score a couple of wins in Alen Wake 2
and Last of Us Part One, but is it
really that impressive of a win when
Nvidia's 8 gig cards can't complete the
test and you just didn't submit your 8
gig card on time for testing? Especially
when we factor in that the 960 XT 16 gig
trails behind the 5060 Ti's and honestly
doesn't even look that stellar against
the 5060 in the remainder of our games
here. If you're wondering, by the way,
about how the 5070 compares to all this,
we didn't retest that card for this
review, so we didn't want to include
stale numbers, but it's a little worse
than the 9070 nonXT from back when we
reviewed that. Moving on to ray tracing.
Despite the massive leap in RT
performance that came with RDNA4, AMD is
still unable to match their direct
Nvidia competitors. In 1080p RT, the
9060 XT falls well behind the 5060Ti 8
gig in our suite of tests, which is sad.
But what really jumped off the charts to
me is Nvidia's embarrassing loss here
with the 5060 not even able to keep up
with the 4060 Ti. I thought they had
improved the ray tracing on Blackwell.
What the heck happened? And in 1440p RT
Cyberpunk, things don't look much
better. Maybe we can find a happier
story in
productivity. No, not really. I mean,
the nice thing about having 16 gigs of
memory, if you do, is that it allows you
to dip your toes into AI without being
as limited. I mean, look at how all the
8 gig cards fumble as we load up a
larger model. But even with 16 gigs, AMD
isn't even close to Nvidia in terms of
performance in our machine learning
tests. It turns out, haha, software
support is important. And that only
becomes more clear as we move beyond AI
to Blender. Optics go br and HIP
go. Adjusting focus to content creation
though, we see big improvements gen over
gen from AMD and they even beat Nvidia
in Da Vinci Resolve, though they trail
behind in the more popular Premier Pro
benchmark. All right, well that's the
performance. So, this has been a big
load of NH so far. But hey, getting 16
gigs of VRAM and 5060 Ti-ish performance
for a theoretical $30 discount, that's
something. It's just it's tough to
justify the $50 jump over the 5060,
whose price is tough to justify over a
kick in the groin. I mean, to AMD's
credit here, FSR4 has made huge strides,
meaning that other than multiframe gen,
which a lot of you aren't that into, AMD
has near par on most of the features
that gamers care about. Even their video
encoder is almost as good as Envank
these days. They just need to work on
third party support for all of this
stuff. So, at the end of the day then, I
don't know. I'm left kind of frustrated.
In recent years, AMD has slowly but
surely caught up to Nvidia in terms of
performance and features, but they've
also caught up in terms of their crappy
behavior. Last gen, the 7600 XT had 16
gigs and the 7600 nonXT had 8 gigs of
VRAM. It was super easy to tell what you
were buying from the name of the
product. This time around, they've
lumped both cards together with the same
XT name and then at the same time, as
far as we can tell, intentionally made
it more difficult for media to review
the 8 gig version, which could lead to
consumer confusion. So AMD, your
commitment to the press words kind of
meaningless at this point. And speaking
of meaningless promises, you still
haven't managed to get your previous
cards into the sales channel anywhere
near MSRP, which means you've
effectively given away any credibility
that you might have had there, too. So
bottom line, if you have 350 bucks or
more to spend, you can buy a 960 XT, I
guess. But I wouldn't recommend the 8
gig one if you want to get a longer
lifespan out of your card or you want to
upgrade your monitor to 1440p. And
whichever one you choose, just don't
smuggly tell yourself that you're
supporting the good guy, because AMD's
actions speak much louder than their
words, and they seem content to just
draft behind Nvidia, both in good ways
and bad, rather than aggressively jump
out in front to delight PC gamers who
don't have $800 plus dollars to spend on
a GPU. AMD, this was kind of your shot.
Nvidia is super distracted at the
moment, and unless you do more, your GPU
division is going to continue to only
resonate with a small niche of users who
don't mind owning a punching bag. And I
would deserve to be punched in the bag
if I didn't segue to our sponsor,
Squarespace. Whether your business is
just getting off the ground or you've
been in the dark ages of cold calling
for a while, a website will give you
that extra push to take things to the
next level. That's where Squarespace
comes in. Their Squarespace blueprint
guided design system gives you the
ultimate starter pack to get the
creative juices flowing with
professionally curated layout and
styling options. Then once you've laid
the foundation, use their fluid engine
editor and its code-free drag and drop
elements to customize to your heart's
content. Your website also comes with
integrated SEO tools and advanced
analytics so you can optimize what's
working and identify what might need a
little tweaking. You can even set up
your website to take payments via credit
card, PayPal, and more. So, head on over
to
squarespace.com/ltt for a free trial and
save 10% on your first purchase of a
website or domain. If you guys enjoyed
this video, go check out our review of
the 9070 and 9070 XT. It dives a little
bit deeper into the architectural
changes with RDNA4.